yes what wha the maturity level of a
twelve-year-old that's just the way I
like it
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mobs Inc
this game was made in three days for the
Ludum dare challenge and I actually just
opened it up to give it a try but it's
actually really fun like this game whoa
no I'm dead oh well I leveled up to the
level 30 nothing hard Diggity damn look
at me go
I actually opened it up just to try but
it's really really cool so this game was
made in three days for the Ludum dare
challenge or Ludum dare game jam and it
actually one because it's got really it
was made in three days look at this
thing that's amazing I mean even though
it is pixel art but some of these pixel
art games take like months to make but
they made this quick press Q to trigger
it powerful hit from above okay cool I'm
like limited office said Oh creepers in
second place and I don't recognize the
one in first but basically the whole
thing oh hey we're right off into it
yeah what is this ooh oh ah so cool Hot
Diggity damn oh it's so cool like it's
something so simplistic and yet there's
something so satisfying about just being
able to smash these so-called heroes you
think you're a hero I don't know what
you are I mean there's some Dark Souls
level difficulty for these poor heroes
I'm just wondering you know whatever I
see these flash games now I like I
appreciate the game developers did them
well and I really want him to be
successful so I'm like oh I think this
might work work well as a mobile game
because it's just so simple and just
clicking where you go Oh at least I made
my boss happy I don't even know if
there's an end game to this at all but
it's just a fun little simple game and I
love fun little simple
James yay Oh what am I now new spell
available in the dungeon press W to
trigger a bouncing ball crosses folks
okay cool
I went from a wizard to a barbarian a
scallop Aryan well Jesus I forgot that's
cut harder huh
you saw nothing first you saw your own
death I think I made it yes when do I
stop I
okay gonna be a little dangerous if I
stopped right when I was about to be
shot that's just like games like that
lik I remember from the old flash era of
games like people made all these
interesting and unique games and then
when phones came about like everyone
stole the concepts just to make like
cash ins with lots of microtransactions
and [ __ ] like that like not cool I
mean awful I'm all for game developers
making money but I'm not all for game
developers like cashing in on other
people's ideas that's a stupid he's so
cool I'm a creepy skeleton I'm gonna
snap your bones out I'm guessing I stab
their bones out to add more bones to my
bone throne that I got bone thrown
sounds like something else completely
but you know you know what I mean right
I'm not making any dirty jokes over here
I'm literally just a skeleton trying to
make bones for my bones room sorry
hahahahahaha you think you can mess with
me yeah oh you have to inflate me Oh
also the animations really cool like the
art style in the animation to Flozell
together really well boss I'm sorry boss
can I get another promotion please yes
Oh God
unlike that boss from icecrown citadel
the first one was his name bone ma bone
bone ma button bone bone bone her owner
boner owner oh but boning bones cone of
the bone thrown a bone blam boom blam
makjang or flam bone zone to the bone
throne bone throne is the bone zone
boning Ikea make him owning the bone
zone on the bone throat got it yes
nailed it yeah oh man I should shut up
okay I got a new spell oh whoa oh my god
oh that's so cool I can stop time I'm
literally literally boss level I've
reached the highest level these poor
bastards don't know what's gonna hit him
oh my god that's so sad for them I'm not
really sad at all how did I not get that
guy's look at a giant sign I guess at
this point it should be expected that
I'm nine and oh oh no I thought I'd aha
gothic and die boss boss
it's okay Oh
oh geez I didn't even know oh now my
bones
they blew my bones are away no boss come
on oh I'm trying real hard cause it's
harder than you'd think
boss corner - never enough boner jokes
but I mean how many boner jokes can you
possibly make out of this I'm just lying
thrown in my bone zone I'm trying to get
a bank loan Freddie get a bank loan to
improve the bone zone and my bones
thrown I'm really making you guys groan
with all these bones fence oh no oh no
oh good do I good last one last run oh
it's the end oh no my boss stoned by
bone zone
if only I grew bone wings and I could
have flown over the bone soon
I need to hone my bone skills maybe
fight a frontal cone bone attack it
would have like you know the cone of the
bone zone hone that it would really be
known that my bones hood was I've been
working out trying to build up my tone
my bone toe evil I should hone and tone
my bone cone so that I could make him
groan and stone him from the bone zone
all the way up on my bone throat yeah I
did it okay I'm sorry
okay so that was mobs ink you can check
out this game in the link in the
description below it's a lot of fun
it was obviously only made in three days
so there's not a lot of substance to the
game but if you want to kill some time
playing a cool game that's a lot of fun
I recommend this one thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you
in the next video bye-bye